the natural way of things is that a game
gets formulated game gets funded game
gets teased at some fancy convention or
PR do and then eventually game comes out
unfortunately that isn't always the case
and some games don't quite make it to
that last stage as a result here's our
list of some big games that went missing
in action a game that incites a pang of
sadness off to the end of every sony e3
conference without its appearance is the
last guardian rumors started spreading
in 2007 about the suspected follow-up to
IKOS Shadow of the Colossus which was
set to feature a boy and a large
creature but not in a scary puppet Oh
sort of way in 2009 the rumored project
tracker was confirmed complete with
trailer and there was even a demo shown
to press in 2011 a late 2011 release was
promised but never delivered upon and
since then the game has slipped back
into the shadows in 2011 murmurings and
job postings for our project called
Titan appeared blizzards follow-up MMO
to world of warcraft we've never seen so
much as a screenshot or an official
confirmation but this one keeps being
hinted at in financial reports at 2016
release date he ran on subscription
model there whether it'll actually ever
eventuate is a whole other thing
remember Rainbow six well Ubisoft to
sort of Patriots came into our lives in
the form of a concept trailer where the
player had to respond to on-screen
prompts that made the whole thing look a
bit david kg and people started calling
it heavy Rainbow six in 2011 we got a
story trailer all about the true
patriots a domestic terrorist
organization and you be told us all
about how they be humanized by letting
us play as them that was right before to
hop members of the dev team were removed
and a new creative director was
appointed in 2012 you be do promise it's
coming along though and apparently now
it'll be the ps4 and Xbox one instead in
2007 rockstar teased a first-person
stealth action game which would be known
as agent it took 2009 z3 for us to get
its name premise and the wildly
idealistic statement from the
ex-president of take-two that agent
could be as big as GTA since then agent
has had the occasional sly mention on an
earnings report in 2011 and that's been
the end of that Ali's for the moment for
player world war 2 action game
brothers-in-arms furious 4 announced at
e3 in 2011 was all set to let you hunt
down Hitler naturally with a premise
that good we've seen nothing other than
a debut trailer and a bevy of delays
between the original release date in
2012 to now gearboxes since reimagined
it its own IP and you we have said they
won't be the publisher but other than
that info on the Hitler slaying title is
slim to nil now let's do the impossible
and try to cover half life 2 episode 3
in a few sentences luckily everybody in
their dog knows what half life is so
let's skip that part the rumor third
installment has been the subject of so
very many memes namely half life 3
confirmed while val boss Gabe Newell has
been endlessly begged for an ounce of
half-life hope this is probably down to
the fact that it's been eight years
since the episodes existence was
confirmed and slapped with a plant
release date in 2007 we've seen concept
art and more mystery files and signs and
valves databases than you can shake a
stick at but it's still just a glimmer
in the eyes of die hard halflife fans
right now in one of the greatest
tragedies of gaming we're still yet to
get an up
on the sequel to 2003's Beyond Good and
Evil the cult hit action game didn't
self so great but gamers were ecstatic
to see a trailer for the second
installment landed a Ubisoft event in
2008 not a whole lot happens but it was
enough to get the fanbase rolling again
unfortunately the game's creator
Michelle Ansell has been pretty damn
busy with Raymond and as a result Beyond
Good and Evil 2 has been well and truly
left by the wayside nonetheless we still
sit with bated breath during every
single ubisoft e3 conference hoping to
see a green bandana or a casually
dressed pig the huge household name of
starcraft was all set to potter over to
the third person stealth action realm
with the conception of starcraft ghost
in 2002 as with an awful lot of these
games the supposed release date which
was to take place in 2003 never really
managed to come to fruition just to put
that into perspective that was when it
would have been coming to ps2 game cube
and the original Xbox dozens of delays
later and after a 2005 playable
multiplayer demo at blizzcon the game
was postponed indefinitely in 2006 I
guess in space no one can hear the
grumbling of fans who actually wanted to
play your m.i.a game that's our wrap of
games we wish hadn't been lost to the
realm of industry circumstances but be
sure to let us know which missing in
action game you'd most like to see be
revived in the comments and check out
our full feature which is on gamespot
now